It's a crazy situation in Europe
that you have to accuse yourself.
Why you use the law enforcement instruments,
you know, to.
To cross the border illegally is a. Is a crime.
Nobody can do that.
If you would like to become a migrant in Hungary,
please knocking on the door,
not kicking it off.
You know, it does not work just to cross.
And they crossed.
And more than 100,000 young,
young physically
while situated migrants arrived to Hungary
and marched through the country and said,
we have to stop it.
Don't forget
that Hungary is the outside border of Shanga.
So when we defend the Hungary and border,
we defend Europe.
Anyway, we defend the Shangun area.
So we. We are serving the Germans